hi everyone
this is professor m das science and
today we're going to talk about the
eigenfunctions of orbital angular
momentum
in another one of our videos on rigorous
quantum mechanics
angular momentum eigenfunctions allows
to describe the states that correspond
to the fixed
quantized eigenvalues of angular
momentum they are central to understand
the hydrogen atom and they also help us
to understand
other systems where spherical symmetry
is important
for example the scattering of particles
by a central potential the mathematical
form of the eigenfunctions is not
particularly easy
but the derivation involves some really
nice math stricts so i think you will
enjoy the video
so let's go orbital angular momentum is
a physical property associated with the
motion of particles in a
three-dimensional euclidean space
as such the most convenient
representation to study orbital angular
momentum
is the position representation and the
most convenient coordinates are
spherical coordinates
these here are the eigenvalue equations
for the orbital angular momentum
operators
l squared and lz
written in the position representation
using spherical coordinates
if you have been following our videos
then you should be familiar with these
equations
but if you want further details you can
check out the background videos on
orbital angular momentum that are linked
in the description
so just as a quick refresher this term
here corresponds to the l squared
operator in the position representation
this here is the eigenfunction which is
the position representation of the
eigenstate
this is the eigenvalue and this is the
eigenfunction again
in the second equation this is the lz
operator in the position representation
this and this are the eigenfunctions
again
and this is the eigenvalue these two
equations
have the same eigenfunctions because l
squared and lz commute
so they form a set of compatible
observables
in the video on orbital angular momentum
eigenvalues
we derive these equations and show that
the only values that l can take are 0 or
positive integers
and that for a given l m can only take
one of the values
minus l minus l plus 1 minus l plus 2
and so on in steps of 1 all the way
up to l minus 1 and l
so we know the eigenvalues from the
corresponding video
and what i want to do in this video is
to determine
the eigenfunctions the angular momentum
operators in the position representation
are differential operators the
derivatives only act
on the theta and phi coordinates and
this implies that the eigenfunction can
be separated into a radial part
and an angular part now as the angular
momentum operators only act on the
angular part we can replace the
eigenfunction
psi in these equations by the y
here and doing that we obtain
this equation for l squared
and this equation for z
so we can now restate the objective of
today's video
we want to figure out what the
eigenfunctions
ylm of these two equations are
the derivation is somewhat mathematical
but rather interesting
and the resulting functions called
spherical harmonics
play a key role in many quantum problems
before we start calculating the
eigenfunctions let's very briefly
discuss
normalization in principle the full wave
function
psi of the system should be normalized
which means that the integral over all
space
of the absolute value squared of the
wave function
must equal 1. remember that as we're
using
spherical coordinates then such an
integral can be rewritten as an integral
over
r squared d r and integral over
sine theta d theta and an integral
over d phi of the absolute value squared
of the wave function
however we've just argued that psi can
be separated into a radial part and an
angular part
so what we will do is to use a
convention by which the normalization
of psi is typically divided into the
separate normalizations of
the radial part and of the angular part
so for our purposes in the rest of the
video we will work with normalized
ylm eigenfunctions
the first step that we will take to
determine the eigenfunctions ylm
is actually something we already did in
the video on eigenvalues because it was
a result
necessary to show that the l and m
quantum numbers can only take integer
values
therefore as we already covered in
detail in that video i'm only going to
sketch it here
we start by noticing that the operator
ilset here only depends on phi
and this means that we can separate the
eigenfunction y
into a function that only depends on
theta multiplied by a function that only
depends
on phi now plugging in
this solution into the lz equation gives
this
and we can cancel the theta dependent
terms and we get an equation for the phi
dependent part
only which we can rewrite like this
this is a straightforward first order
differential equation
whose general solution is that glm of
phi
is equal to some constant a times e to
the power of
i m phi so the main result of this slide
is that we can write the angular
momentum eigenfunction
ylm as equal to
f times e to the i and phi where i have
absorbed the normalization constant into
f
right that was the easy part the rest
will not be so straightforward but i
think it is rather neat
for the next step we're going to exploit
the properties of the ladder operators
let's start with the rating operator l
plus
we know from the video on general
angular momentum eigenvalues
that when the raising operator acts on
the eigenstate
ll which is the eigenstate for which m
takes its maximum value
l then the result is zero
we also know from the introductory video
on orbital angular momentum
that we can write the rating operator in
the position representation
and using spherical coordinates like
this
using the result we got for the y
eigenfunction
up here in the case when m equals l we
get
this and we can now use this expression
for the eigen function together with
this expression for l plus
to rewrite this equation in the position
representation
so overall we get this
the first thing we can do is to divide
through by this pre-factor
because the right-hand side is zero
then the first partial derivative only
affects the
f term and the second partial derivative
only affects the phi dependent
exponential
this means that when we operate on the
eigenfunction
we first get the result of the theta
derivative
and then the result of the phi
derivative
all of which equals zero
this is simply i l times e to the i l
phi we can therefore divide through
by e to the il phi
and we can also combine i with il
to get i squared l which is equal to
minus l
putting all of these together we end up
with this equation for f
which only involves the theta variable
it is a first order differential
equation which we can solve by
separation of variables
so let's rearrange it and here i've used
the fact that
one over the tangent is equal to cosine
over sine
we can now integrate both sides with
respect to theta
and we can actually simplify the right
hand side to this
using the fact that d sine theta is
equal to cos theta d
theta evaluating the integrals we obtain
the logarithm of
f and l times the logarithm of sine
theta
plus some integration constant
using the properties of the logarithm we
can write this here
and finally we can exponentiate to get
this and the integration constant is now
here we're almost there
we can now use this final expression for
fll
and insert it all the way up here in the
eigenfunction
yl
so this here is our latest expression
for the eigenfunction
yll all that is left to do is to
calculate the normalization constant
cl although this may look trivial it
turns out that the calculation is a
little involved
so what i will do for now is just to
quote the result
which is that cl equals minus 1 to the
power of l
divided by 2 to the l times l factorial
multiplying the square root of 2l plus 1
factorial
over 4 pi if you're mathematically
minded and want to see the calculation
of cl
which is actually quite fun because it
uses some neat maths then you can find
it later on
in this same video but for now let's
just assume this result
and go back to the eigenfunction y
allele
we can now write it as the normalization
constant
sine theta to the power l and e to the
power
il phi so that's it
this is the eigen function for the case
m equals l
to determine the rest of the eigen
functions we resort again to the
properties of the ladder operators
in this case of lowering operator l
minus we know that its action
on an angular momentum eigenstate lm
is equal to this prefactor
times another angular momentum
eigenstate l m
minus 1. therefore once we have the
eigen function
y l l that we have just calculated we
can apply the lowering operator once to
get
y l l minus 1 and applying it again we
get y
l l minus 2 and so on all the way to
y l minus l
to do this we need to write down the
lowering operator l
minus in the position representation
which we already did in the introductory
video on orbital angular momentum
and this is the relevant expression
we then simply apply this lowering
operator starting
from the m equals l eigenfunction and
in this way we can generate all the
eigenfunctions with all possible values
of
n in addition this pre-factor here
already ensures normalization so we only
have to worry about normalizing the
starting state
yl and then all of the rest will follow
all this means that the strategy to
generate all the eigenfunctions is
conceptually
very simple but in practice calculating
the maths is rather tedious
so if we carried out these calculations
we would find
that the eigenfunctions of the angular
momentum operators
l squared and lz labeled ylm
are given by this admittedly long
expression
these eigenfunctions are called
spherical harmonics
as you can imagine you don't have to
remember them
it's good to do the derivation once but
from now on
whenever you need the orbital angular
momentum eigenfunctions
all you need to do is look them up in
the literature
however when you do that you do need to
be cautious
depending on the literature that you
consult you may find
different expressions for the spherical
harmonics these different expressions
are of course mathematically equivalent
but
it's important to be aware of which form
you're using
okay so what we've discussed so far is
the general strategy to calculate these
spherical harmonics
from a conceptual point of view we have
sketched
every step of the calculation however we
haven't really carried out every
mathematical step explicitly because
many of the steps are a bit convoluted
so feel free to stop here pause the
video
if you're satisfied with simply knowing
that these
are the spherical harmonics but if
you're curious to see in some more
detail the mathematics involved
then what i will do in the rest of this
video is to show you how to calculate
the normalization
cl up here in detail
the derivation is actually quite fun and
involves some really neat maths
including among other things interesting
integrals and recurrence relations
so if you're continuing with me let's
get going
so this here is the latest expression
that we got for the eigenfunction
yll where all that was left to calculate
was the normalization constant
cl as we've discussed earlier we require
that the integral over all the angular
variables
equals 1. using the expression for
yll that we just derived we have that
the argument of the integral
is this so that we can rewrite the
integral like this
the phi integral is trivial and gives to
pi
and we can now isolate the absolute
value squared of cl
and get this
this object here is a definite integral
over the variable
theta so it will be some number which we
have to determine
but for now i will just call it il
so that we can write cl like this
so all we have left to do is to
calculate il
the first step is to make a variable
substitution
let u be cos theta so that d u
is minus sin theta d theta for the
integration limits when
theta is zero then u is cos zero which
is
one and when theta is pi then
u is cos pi which is minus one looking
at the argument of the integral
we can rewrite it like this and then
using the standard result from
trigonometry that the sum of the cosine
squared and the sine squared equals 1
we get this putting everything together
we can rewrite the integral like this
and reversing the integration limit we
get this
the next step is to rewrite the argument
1 minus u squared to the power l
as 1 minus u squared times everything
else
so multiplying through we get this
and we can therefore rewrite the
integral il
as equal to two terms the first comes
from this one and
is this and the second one comes from
this one
and is this
this term here is simply il minus one
and we have to figure out what this one
is
so here i have the integral il that
we're interested in
and this is the term that we have left
to calculate
to do so we first need an intermediate
result
consider the derivative with respect to
u of this quantity
which is equal to l times one minus u
squared to the power
l minus one multiplied by the derivative
of the bracket
which is minus 2u
rearranging we get this
leaving this result on the side for a
moment we can now rewrite our integral
like this
all we've done is to multiply by minus
2l here
and divide by the same quantity here and
then separated
the u squared into this u and this u
now very conveniently we now have this
bracket here that is equal to this
so we can rewrite our integral like this
in this form it is now straightforward
to use integration by parts to get the
pre-factor
the first term and the second term
this term vanishes because this is zero
at the integration limits
so we end up with this
integral is our definition of il
so we end up with 1 over 2 l times
i l going back to our original integral
for il
up here we can now write i l
as i l minus 1 minus 1
over 2 l times i l
we can now rearrange this expression to
isolate i
l
so we haven't actually yet found what il
is what we have found is the value of
il given the value of il minus 1.
this is called a recurrence relation and
all we need is
just to get started to do so let's
consider
the case l equals 0 which gives i 0
equal to this
which we can very easily evaluate and
we get 2. so going back to our
recurrence relation
it is valid for any value of l so in
particular if we pick
l minus 1 we get this expression in
terms of i
l minus 2 by replacing all l's by
l minus ones the pre-factor combines to
get
this putting together these two
expressions we get this
and we see that the numerator here
decreases by
two to get here and so does the
denominator
repeating this procedure we eventually
get to an expression in terms of i
zero and we can actually write this in a
more compact form
using the double factorial
the double factorial is defined in the
usual way multiplying all the way down
skipping every other number we also know
from up here that i zero is equal to two
so in principle we are done
however we're going to rewrite this
expression in a slightly more convenient
form
this here is the latest expression that
we got for il in terms of double
factorials
let's start by quoting two general
results about double factorials
i will not prove them but they're
actually very easy to understand
the double factorial of an integer n is
equal to the factorial of
n divided by the double factorial of n
minus 1.
to understand this remember that this
double factorial skips every other term
this factorial includes all terms so
dividing by this double factorial which
is offset by 1 from the original one
gives the required result now using this
result we can rewrite
the 2l plus 1 double factorial as equal
to this for the second result
consider an even number m equal to 2k
for some other integer k then m
double factorial is equal to 2 to the
power of k
times the factorial of k and again
this is easy to understand because the
factorial over k starts from half the
value of
m and then multiplying each term by 2
gives the proper m sequence and we have
k
such terms so using this result
for 2l double factorial we get this
and we're now ready to go back to il
if we first use this expression for the
denominator we get
this we can then use this expression for
the numerator
and we get this
and simplifying we get this result
and now we can finally go back to our
normalization factor cl up here
and we can now write it in terms of this
later result that we got
taking the square root of both sides and
reorganizing somewhat
we get that the absolute value of c l is
equal to
1 over 2 to the l times l factorial
multiplying the square root of 2 l plus
1 factorial divided by 4 pi
cl is in principle a complex number so
we still have to determine its face
this face choice is of course arbitrary
because we only ever get
the absolute value squared of this
quantity
in quantum mechanics so we could in
principle pick
any value for the face the usual
convention though is to make a face
choice such that even and odd values of
l have a different sign so finally we
get
cl equal to this
and this time we really are done
this is the expression for cl that we
used earlier on
to build the full expression for the m
equals l
spherical harmonic
spherical harmonics are the eigen
functions of orbital angular momentum
although their mathematical form is not
particularly simple
they are very important in many systems
for example the hydrogen atom spherical
harmonics are also rather beautiful when
visualized
so i really encourage you to check them
out and as always if you liked the video
please subscribe